así
hasta ahora hemos hablado de cómo crear
una hoja de pastor usando un arco
parabólico y como parámetro de la
anchura en pizzas nos referimos a este
tipo de creación de geometría como
modelado también hemos hablado de cómo
crear un color y nos referimos a eso
como hating ahora hablemos sobre algo
más emocionante la animación cómo hacer
que una hoja de pasto se mueva observen
cómo en esta escena el pasto se mueve
suavemente dando a entender que hay un
viento suave a este tipo de movimiento
sutil le llamamos mantener vivo porque
si no había ningún movimiento parecería
que está inmóvil o muerto pero no
queremos mucho movimiento para que no
quite la atención de lo que el director
quiere que veas
entonces como animamos cada hoja
bueno para animar solo necesito saber en
dónde está cada punto de control en cada
cuadro de la animación así que solamente
grabo el movimiento conforme lo muevo
esta es una pequeña animación muy simple
y creo que quizá esos cuadros son
suficientes y ahora puedo reproducir
esta animación tantas veces como quiera
en este caso simplemente estoy
reproduciendo el ciclo una y otra vez en
la animación entonces así es como se ve
esta hoja de pasto cuando el animamos y
así es como se ve el movimiento cuando
se duplica en un montón de hojas de
pasto ya empezamos a darnos una idea de
cómo se debe de mover un campo de pasto
pero en este caso todas las hojas de
pasto se mueven exactamente igual lo
cual no es muy realista pero podemos
agregar un poco de variación si hacemos
que cada hoja empiece la animación a un
tiempo diferente y eso es lo que puedo
controlar con este deslizador así puedo
agregar poca o mucha variación ahora ya
empieza a verse mucho más realista
esta es una forma de agregar variación
otra forma de agregar variación es usar
dispersión de hecho usamos dispersión
tan comúnmente de tantas formas
diferentes que vamos a dedicar un
tutorial completo a eso pero por ahora
use el extra interactivo para ver si
pueden animar dos tomas diferentes una
con un poco de mantener vivo como en un
día tranquilo y otro que se vea como en
un día con mucho viento o tormenta